F
IT'S A HOT MARKET OR NOT.
NO DOUBT ANOTHER BIG
DISAPPOINTMENT FOR ALL THE MOB
IN THE MEDIA ESPECIALLY FAKE CNN
AND THAT IS THE TOPIC OF
TONIGHT'S OPENING MONOLOGUE.
BEGINNING IN 2015, THE NETWORK'S
PRESIDENT, WE CALLED HIM
AFFECTIONATELY MR. POTATO HEAD,
JEFF ZUCKER CASHED IN ON THE
LEFT'S ANTI-TRUMP.
AS A RESULT, FAQs, JOURNALISM
TOOK A BACKSEAT HAS THE
ANTI-TRUMP RADICAL CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, THE HOAX, THE RUMORS,
THE SMEARS DOMINATED COVERAGE
24/7 FOR OVER THREE YEARS AND
THAT WORKED BREATHLESSLY TELLING
THEIR VIEWERS THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES
DONALD TRUMP COLLUDED WITH
RUSSIA TO STEAL THE ELECTION
READ HILLARY IS THE ONLY ONE WE
KNOW OF THAT HAD A DIRTY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION DOSSIER.
THEY DIDN'T SPEND MUCH TIME ON
THAT.
IN JUNE OF 2017, THREE FAKE NEWS
CNN EMPLOYEES RESIGNED AFTER
REPORTING A FAKE STORY ABOUT A
RUSSIAN INVESTMENT FIRM WITH
TIES TO TRUMP OFFICIALS ALSO
JUNE 2017.
CNN AGAIN FORCED TO ISSUE A
CORRECTION BECAUSE OF A FAKE
STORY ABOUT JIM COMEY'S RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
DECEMBER 2017, CNN PROPAGATED A
STORY ABOUT TRUMP'S ADVISOR AND
THE RUSSIA AND A 2017, FAKE NEWS
CNN PUBLISHING A FAKE STORY
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP JR. AND
WIKILEAKS THAT IN JULY 2018,
MORE FAKE RUSSIAN NEWS.
THIS TIME FEATURING THE
TRUMP TOWER MEETING.
IN JULY OF 2019, AT LEAST ONE
FAKE NEWS CNN HOST WAS STILL
ACCUSING TRUMP OF RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
DID THEY MISS THAT STORY?
FALL STORY, FAKE NEWS AND OF
COURSE THE UNETHICAL REPORTING
DIDN'T BEGIN AND END WITH
RUSSIA.
MAY 2018, THEY ALSO BASHED TRUMP
FOR PUTTING MIGRANT KIDS IN
CAGES BASED ON A 2014 PHOTO.
THAT WOULD BE WHEN OBAMA AND
THEN VICE PRESIDENT SIPPY CUP
WAS IN OFFICE AND IN
SEPTEMBER 2018, THE NETWORK ALL
BUT ACCUSED BRETT KAVANAUGH OF
BEING GUILTY OF EVERY CHARGE
MADE AGAINST HIM AND IN JANUARY
OF 2019, MULTIPLE SO-CALLED
JOURNALISTS AT CNN SLANDERING A
15-YEAR-OLD BOY WEARING A MAGGOT
AND INITIALLY SETTLED OUT OF
COURT.
I WOULD BET IT'S TENS OF
MILLIONS.
CLEARLY, IT IS HYPER OBSESSIVE
IN THEIR PURSUIT TO SMEAR ALL
THINGS DONALD TRUMP 24/7.
THEY GOT IT WRONG OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
NEVER APOLOGIZE, NEVER CORRECTED
THE RECORD AND CLEARLY, THEY ARE
NEVER GOING TO CHANGE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SOURCES NOW TELLING CNN THAT
MICHAEL COHEN CLAIMS THEN
CANDIDATE TRUMP DESPITE HIS MANY
DENIALS SINCE NEW IN ADVANCE
ABOUT THAT JUNE 2016 TRUMP TOWER
MEETING.
>> CALLING FOR THE BLOCK NUMBER
AND OTHER SEEMS TO BE GOOD
EVIDENCE THAT WAS PROBABLY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> THE FORMER CAMPAIGN CHAIRMAN
PAID SECRET VISITS, MULTIPLE TO
.>> WHAT A GREAT CASE OFFICER
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S, HE KNOWS HOW
TO HANDLE AN ASSET AND THAT'S
WHAT HE'S DOING WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE DOSSIER HAS
BEEN CORROBORATED BY THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY.
>> SAID THIS PLAN WOULD PROVIDE
LITTLE BENEFIT FOR PEOPLE OF
WEALTH LIKE HIMSELF GREAT IS
THAT TRUE?
>> IN A WORD, NO.
>> Sean: IT WAS PRETTY MUCH
EVERY HOUR, EVERY SECOND OF ANY
24-HOUR DAY AND MOST ANALYSTS
OVER THERE AT FAKE NEWS CNN
LAUGHABLY REFERRED TO THEMSELVES
AS UNBIASED JOURNALISTS,
SOMETHING THEY ARE NOT WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE A STENOGRAPHER FOR
JEFF ZUCKER, NOT A JOURNALIST,
HE IS A PARTISAN HACK, DOES
WHATEVER JEFF ZUCKER TELLS HIM
TO DO AND DESPITE HIS TITLE AS A
MEDIA CORRESPONDENT, HE FOCUSES
ALMOST ALL OF HIS EFFORTS ON
PRETTY MUCH STOCKING THIS
NETWORK AND YOURS TRULY, WHICH
IS SOMEWHAT AMUSING.
BUT ACTUALLY HAS A WEEKEND SHOW
ON FAKE NEWS CNN THAT NOT THAT
MANY PEOPLE WATCH COME A LITTLE
OVER 700,000 AND THAT WOULD BE A
TOTAL DISASTER IN ANYBODY ELSE'S
WORLD AND GET THIS, HIS NEW BOOK
1,738 COPIES AND TONIGHT, GOT TO
GIVE HIM CREDIT DURING HIS MOST
RECENT SHOW, HE WAS APOPLECTIC
OVER MY COVERAGE OF JOE BIDEN
AND HIS PROTECTORS IN THE MEDIA
MOB, HAD A BIT OF A MELTDOWN
OVER IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU HAVE TO HEAR THE
POISONOUS PROPAGANDA THAT THE
G.O.P. ACTIVIST BASES LISTENING
TO YOU.
HE'D HAVE TO REALLY HEAR IT.
IT'S COMING MORE FROM
SEAN HANNITY THEN FROM TRUMP
RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S WHAT WE GET THIS WEEK.
WE WATCHED EVERY EPISODE OF
SEAN HANNITY'S SHOW AND WE
COLOR-CODED IT, FOCUSED ON HIS
LANGUAGE, THE INSULTS AND
PHRASES THAT HE REPEATS EVERY
NIGHT, NASTY LITTLE WORDS.
DON'T GET NUMB TO THIS ABUSIVE
LANGUAGE BECAUSE IT IS THROUGH
THESE INSULTS AND THESE ATTACKS
THAT HANNITY BUILDS POWER.
THIS DARK, DIRE LANGUAGE IS
FUNDAMENTALLY AUTHORITARIAN.
IT'S NOT OPINION WHAT HANNITY
DOES.
IT HAS BEEN THE DEFENSE, WE HAVE
OPINION SHOWS.
NO.
SAYING YES, WE SHOULD KEEP THE
2017 TAX CUTS AND PLACES AN
OPINION.
LET'S EXPAND UNIVERSAL PRE-K,
THAT'S AN OPINION.
HANNITY IS SPOUTING POISON.
>> Sean: DEFINITION OF POISE
AND MUST MEAN THAT I TELL THE
TRUTH THAT HIS BOOK AND HIS
SHOWS A FAILURE.
ANYWAY, NOT ONLY CLAIMS TO BE
THE GREAT ARBITER OF TRUTH, BUT
NOW ACCORDING TO HIM HE IS ALSO
THE ARBITER OF WHAT IS
ACCEPTABLE OPINIONS.
ANY ADJECTIVE THAT OFFENDS HIM
IS POISON LIKE TELLING THE TRUTH
ABOUT HIM AND YOU WATCHED YOUR
OWN CHANNELS PROGRAMMING OVER
THE LAST FIVE YEARS, FAILED TO
REPORT ON ALL OF THE FAILURES OF
YOUR NETWORK, ONE CNN ANALYST
FANTASIZING ABOUT PUNCHING
15-YEAR-OLD NICHOLAS SANDMANN IN
THE FACE FOR THE CRIME OF
WEARING A HAT.
OTHERS REFERRING TO TRUMP
SUPPORTER'S AS KLANSMEN, NAZIS
AND DOMESTIC TERRORISTS THAN
THAT OF COURSE IS ONLY THE TIP
OF THE ICEBERG.
YOU DECIDE.
>> IS THIS PRESIDENT TRYING TO
IMPERSONATE HUGO CHAVEZ?
>> TRUMP IS AS DESTRUCTIVE A
PERSON IN THIS CENTURY AS
HITLER, STALIN, AND MAO WERE IN
THE LAST CENTURY.
HE MAY BE RESPONSIBLE FOR MANY
MORE MILLION DEATHS THAN THEY
WERE.
>> THAT SOUNDS A LOT LIKE A
CERTAIN LEADER THAT GUILD
MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY AND
6 MILLION OTHER IN THE 1940s.
>> WHAT YOU CALL SOMEONE WHO
SAYS CLEARLY RACIST THINGS?
THIS MORNING, THE ANSWER IS
MR. PRESIDENT.
>> HE IS A DEMAGOGUE, A
HATEMONGER AND IS BRINGING
FASCISM TO AMERICA.
>> SO INSULTING AND SO MANY
WAYS, SUCH A CRYBABY.
IT'S JUST DISGUSTING.
>> SOUNDS LIKE AN AUTOCRAT
OUSTED FROM POWER.
>> Sean: HITLER, STALIN, AND
MAO.
DID YOU CATCH ANY OF THAT?
ARE YOU TOO BUSY WATCHING US
OVER HERE AT FOX?
ULTIMATELY, HE IS PROJECTING AND
LASHING OUT, UPSET THAT HE HAS
BEEN MOCKED AND HUMILIATED A LOT
AS OF LATE.
IN HIS RE-RELEASED BOOK WITH 13
NEW CHAPTERS, 13 OF THEM, SOLD
1,738 COPIES IN THE FIRST WEEK,
NOW OVER 5,000 ON AMAZON
BEST SELLER LIST DESPITE MASSIVE
NATIONWIDE P.R. CAMPAIGN.
SOMEBODY ELSE THAT WORKS AND HIS
FAMILY, I'LL BE KIND TONIGHT
ACCORDING TO "NEW YORK MAGAZINE"
NOW BEING ACCUSED OF WORKPLACE
BULLYING AND CNN'S FAKE NEWS
RATINGS HAVE PLUMMETED A
WHOPPING 75%.
THINGS ARE NOT GOING WELL FOR
HIM OR ANYBODY AT FAKE NEWS CNN
BUT MARK MY WORDS, HE WILL NEVER
POLICE MY RECORD A